charlotte uh incredible scenes uh there
over the last few hours in kabul what is
the situation uh right now that the
taliban are full in full control we know
they they spoke uh a few minutes ago
about what their plans were for the
country
yeah zabihullah mujahid who is a
spokesman for the taliban he it was a
message of reassurance for afghans then
also almost a pitch towards the
international community on an economic
front we know the economy is at the
forefront of their minds it's a big
concern and he said we know we need
international investment we want the
international community to engage we
want to coordinate with them on projects
and plans if they have any issues we
want them to come to us so we can find
solutions we think that it will take a
few years for us to find our feet and
really fulfill our potential but we need
the international community for that as
long as it is in line with our values
we're prepared to do deals with whoever
he also spoke to afghans themselves
saying we know you are scared we know
you don't trust us but we want to work
with you we want we think of you as ours
and we respect you each individually he
has a little bit more of what he said
we should turn a new chapter we should
bury the hatchet we have no animosity
against any particular faction party or
individual we transcend above this all
this is a closed chapter of our history
we are looking forward to the future
with one goal in sight rebuilding our
country
charlotte uh uh what's the current
situation at the uh at the airport right
now as the taliban try to get that get
the airport back up and running
we've just been at the airport it is
quite airy compared to what it has been
like the chaos the thousands of people
who have been down there over the last
two weeks banging on the gates to get in
it is very quiet there is a wide
security perimeter held by taliban
special forces outside there are many
taliban inside the airport surveying the
scene looking at what the americans have
left behind and trying to figure out how
do we operate this airport what skills
do we need what equipment do we need
what have we got on deck here that's
still functional that we can use we went
to the military side and the commercial
side and here's our report from there
we're on the military side of the
airport this is where the americans
vacated from last night you can still
see their planes equipment helicopters
here the taliban brought us here and
last night their mood was one of joy
celebration they were shooting in the
sky there were there were fireworks they
were very happy that the americans had
left the mood here today is quite
different they are disappointed they are
angry they say they feel betrayed
because
all of this equipment is broken beyond
repair they say that they expected the
americans to leave helicopters like this
in one piece for their use when i said
to them
why do you think that the americans
would have left everything operational
for you they said because we believe it
is a national asset and we are the
government now and this could have come
to great use for us so they are very
disappointed that a lot of this
equipment
cannot be used any longer
over to my left is where the commercial
side of the airport is
zabihullah mujahid who's a spokesman for
the taliban said that they hope to have
this area operational in the coming days
which would allow people who want to fly
out on commercial flights to do so with
visas so while the evacuation efforts
have finished because foreign forces
have all left
the taliban say that they are going to
stand by their word which is to allow
people to fly out commercially when they
get everything operational we understand
that turkey and qatar are assisting that
with them i can tell you that i saw
dozens of people arrive even to our own
hotel with equipment and personnel
ready to support the airport getting
back on its feet
engineers that type of thing
to try and get these these planes
running again but here on the military
side nothing will be operational any
time in the future the taliban
disappointed as this is what the
americans have left behind
well let's talk now to osama bin laden
who is in eastern afghanistan with
exclusive access to the city of
jalalabad so osama what is it like for
people on the taliban rule now
well just about a few minutes ago we
heard from taliban leaders who'd
gathered in the main square
they were telling people that the system
of corruption is over they were telling
people that there is going to be a
system of judicial justice they said
that now taliban will implement a system
which does not uh empower the powerful
but actually tries and go supports the
oppressed and this is promises that
we've heard from the taliban before but
this was different because the audience
with the taliban were speaking to were
people of jalalabad people who had
gathered from various locations and come
to the main ground and interestingly
enough just a few minutes after they
left now we can see a football team
playing as it was there's quite a lot of
people in the streets
and life continues to go on as normal in
jalalabad taliban came a little earlier
than the fall of kabul and people have
been accustomed to
taliban in the streets uh residents we
spoke to say that they are happy that
there is at least no lawlessness
there's no uh corruption on the streets
they're not being asked to pay bribes uh
on the checkpoints and it is
beginning to get a little better but
people are apprehensive because they
don't know and they still remember the
taliban from 20 years ago
and are the taliban clear on on how they
will rule afghanistan
well that is something that we've been
asking them and that is something that
people
are puzzled about as well because
there's a lot of angst about our taliban
going to ban uh all sorts of gatherings
will people have to grow long beards
will women have to cover up forcibly uh
but according to all of the taliban we
are at the governor's house now and
we've been speaking to officials at a
provincial level here in jalalabad and
they've been telling us that they want
to assure people that this is not the
taliban that they remember from 20 years
ago they want to tell people that what
was happening 20 years ago was not the
real taliban it was
blown out of proportion the media was
projecting them and this is something
that we've uh heard in their speeches as
well but according to the taliban
leaders they say there is going to be a
system which empowers uh the downtrodden
uh which is just and which brings power
so that people feel as equals in society
now how does it actually translate into
actions i think that is going to be the
real test because taliban have only been
here for a few weeks and people are
still
trying to get to terms of what life is
going to be like under the taliban so
far uh people who we've been speaking to
uh say that they're actually happy that
at least there is very little corruption
and the killings and kidnappings have
stopped
osama bin javid in jalalabad thank you